[Music]
time now for final exam where you put
the news professionals against one
another to see who's been paying closest
attention tonight really the matchup of
the century the topics while it may be
hard to believe but there were news
stories this past week that have nothing
to do with judicial confirmations did
anyone notice that we're about to find
out
joining us Greg Gutfeld host to the Beck
Gutfeld show star the five judge Jeanine
Pirro host of Justice with judge Jeanine
okay you both know the rules as avid
weekly viewers of this game I'm gonna
repeat them for our viewers just turning
in contestants Hannah's hands on buzzers
I ask the questions the first one of you
to buzz in gets to answer the question
this is the tough one you must wait
until I finish asking in order to answer
Oh question once I acknowledge you by
saying your name okay here we go okay
first one the most famous face at the
Pennsylvania gubernatorial debate this
week was the moderator the candidates
were questioned by which longtime TV
game show host judge Jean Pierre Oh Alex
Turner no really
yes so let's all right tape she's right
Alex Trebek the host of Jeopardy
tolerate if you direct us at the
candidates
wrong game all right good job
Wagner's running for governor and you
are exactly I know him question to which
world leader is featured in a popular
new calendar that shows him riding a
horse cuddling a leopard and posing
shirtless with a fish why are we
supposed to be against Putin anyway
let's find out right there's a Putin
with a pup Putin with a cub Putin on a
horse in winter and even colder
Putin taking the Epiphany dip in ice
water if a foreigner biases calendars it
will definitely have a good impression
of our president and they'll see that he
can do it all he loves animals he can
shoot he looks good and loves sport I
detect a kind of sarcastic tone in there
I know I think it's the very bits very
raw make Vlad great again I say I'm not
against epiphany dips all right
question three this is a multiple choice
rapper Kanye West is Washington's newest
diplomat he says he wants to arrange a
sit-down meeting between Donald Trump
and someone the president has long
feuded with who is that person is it a
wait it's okay everyone's alright let me
get them all to a choice okay you got
three choices anchors on the show okay
the question goes to Jeanine Pirro first
according to our judges because mr.
gutfeld violated the cardinal rules
[Music]
three choices Robert DeNiro Colin
Kaepernick or Rosie O'Donnell all right
let's see
I've been calling Colin this morning
reaching him so I could bring Colin to
the White House and we can remove that
son's statement and we can be on the
same page so you said before the show
you thought you would do badly because
you will not follow illegal news but
that's not true when I'm awake well yeah
wait well all right see if you can get
this one question for the Prime Minister
of Great Britain Theresa
they made headlines around the world
when she started an important speech
with an awkward dance she was dancing
like a robot to a 1970s disco song by a
Swedish pop band which song was it you
are just jumping the gun
every time judges what do you think to
greg gutfeld well I would say it's ABBA
do you need the name of the song aside
ooh that's a queen you're so honest is
it dancing queen by ABBA
[Applause]
[Music]
crazy
to to the contestants where one haven't
stay within the lines
final question we'll see if you can you
ready this is a New York City
researchers are about to begin work on a
new census this time they are not
counting people however they're focusing
on a small furry creature in Central
Park what kind of animal is it no are
they counting when you have cable news
anchors on your show say the host of the
program is allowed to add live on his
own scripts I think you know but you
answer it is it why would it not be rats
is it squirrels this is literally the
most contentious show we've ever had
yeah we're gonna give much we're gonna
give one to you later for our viewers I
just want to get quickly subscribe night
after night as a Washington Post writer
terms that he's not he works for a
website I guess connect to the post in
some way owned by Jeff Bezos if you
don't know who he is we have video this
is Eric
when pal or whemple or whatever the guy
on the mug watch benign Mitzvah and
Jewish weddings what a publication how
do they do all this great content for
free
Oh
[Music]
you can't get enough that we got more on
our Facebook page that strongly
recommend it you know we have a crack
research team he's gonna be on your
coffee mug from here on out there he is
Eric wimp out from the Washington Post
affiliated whatever e morning I'm gonna
wake up there you go and judging one for
you is on the way you're gonna want it
when you get it the first something we
will be right back thank you